ensuite avec bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous à leur première
question comment le variant sud africain
est il arrivé sur l'île le porteur du
virus et il
isolé aujourd'hui le connaissant
viennent d'eux parce que ça doit sans
doute prélevés il fêtait médical mais
une chose est certaine c'est que ce
virus est arrivé à mayotte par le
truchement des échanges humains entre
mayotte et l'archipel voisin
mais il ya aussi ces arrivées avec l'un
des signes tous les jours qui mettent en
danger la population de sorte que nous
avons des doutes très fort quand à la
con succès des mesures qui sont prises
on peut toujours continuer à interdire
les vols internationaux à l'arrivée
rallye vers bagnols mais si rien n'est
fait pour endiguer le flux migratoires
dans les cercles ont dépeint ici
le virus continue à arriver à ses filets
donc nous sommes extrêmement sceptique
quant à la qualité de l'analyse aussi
longtemps on nous annoncera on nous
annonce un pas forcément des moyens de
contrôle et prime exemptée par des pays
voisins comme bayonne dans une longue
lettre vous intervenez justement le
gouvernement vous lui demander d'agir ou
au plus vite concrètement quels sont vos
demandes
les demandes sont relativement simples
avec le ministre de la santé a annoncé
dès maintenant qu'elle n'avait pas prévu
d'envoyer à mayotte a un super projet la
terre donc seul en voiture congélateurs
ont suivi l'envoi des dossiers vaccins
nous avons nous avons ici que les
populations à 10 et présente quelques
choses sont quinze mille deux mille
personnes donc la boîte de 12
les doses suffisantes pour vacciner 15
personnes un magnet n'avons pas les
difficultés qu'ont fait rencontrer
ailleurs où les gens sont spécifiques
quant à l'intérêt de ces vases ou au
contraire les masses et mauvais sont ces
vendeurs de vaccins donc il faut je
crois à l'ilfis ccd vacciner les
populations à risque une fois à lévis
d'abord parce construirait mais surtout
parce que nous avons des infrastructures
médicales six autres en état de tout ici
quand on parle de
désert médical et ici ça représente les
réalités donc si nous voulons éviter
conçoivent dans les situations des
semences de tension à l'hôpital de
mamoudzou il faut absolument qu'ils
soient vaccinés au plus vite
et deuxième chose dm direction je pense
que là aussi on fera pas l'économie qui
nous voulons lawzi pouvoir vivre un peu
en paix nous devons vite venir en aide
au titre de la coopération médicale avec
nos voisins notamment maurice ou
probablement et alizée 7
ce virus sud africain et enfin vous le
disais tantôt en août on fera pas
l'économie d'une utilisation complète
les mains tachées citation complète de
deux de nos frontières
dernière question très rapidement si les
hospitalisations venait à être de plus
en plus nombreuse due à la flambée des
cas est-ce que mayotte serait en mesure
de gérer la situation
non pas du tout mais ce n'est pas tout
pour à mesure nous avons que celui des
réanimations à mayotte alors on essaie
de jongler avec les évacuations
sanitaires et la réunion et les
réunionnais que je peux comprendre qu'on
commente à toussoter ne comprennent pas
pour leur avoir des malades pas et donc
je crois que il faut absolument éviter
des tensions au niveau de quelques
baquets à l'hôpital
pour cela il pourra tenir les gens sous
le sceau de l'urgence merci beaucoup
mansour kamardine d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes député de mayotte